welcome back to machine learning Street
talk I'm your host Tim scarf
now today on the show we're joined by Dr
Walid saber who's just written a review
of the book machines will never rule the
world artificial intelligence without
fear written by jobs landgreb and Barry
Smith
now Dr saber will be discussing his
review which provides a detailed
analysis of the book's arguments that
strong AI is impossible
in his review Dr saber acknowledges the
argument made by landgreen Smith that
anything we engineer is ultimately a
system which can be mathematically
modeled and described he then goes on to
discuss the complexity of modeling
mental processes which the authors argue
are Dynamic adaptive continuously
evolving and constitutes systems whose
Behavior affects and is affected by the
environment they function in
he also touches on the notion of
granularity arguing that complex systems
are all the way up from specific
components of the mind to the Mind
itself and that no known mathematics can
model them
Dr saber then delves into the
complexities of language an open
interactive dialogues asserting that
language is a prerequisite for any
artificial general intelligence but that
linguistic communication itself is a
complex system that no mathematics can
model
he doesn't subscribe to the argument
that interactive Bots can be built in
narrow domains since responses and the
overall context cannot be predicted in
any meaningful way
Dr subber has two reservations as to the
conclusions made by Lang Webb and Smith
he questions their use of the word never
and suggests there could be a new
mathematics that mental processes
require that is yet to be discovered
he also doesn't believe that the fact
that complex Behavior cannot be
mathematically modeled precludes the
possibility of building such systems as
evidenced by the intentional programming
language lisp and he also considers the
possibility of hyper computation
invalidating the church touring
hypothesis we'll talk about that a bit
later
finally Dr saber expresses his regrets
that the book didn't go for into further
detail on the frame problem in Ai and
calls for further research into belief
Revision in complex systems
join us today as we speak with Dr Walid
supper about his review of this book
that we've just been speaking about
machines will never rule the world and
by the way I think very highly of Walid
I think he is one of our most loved
guests he is a polymath he has an
incredible breadth of knowledge across
so many fields you know from Ai and
Computer Science and Mathematics to
philosophy to Linguistics he really is a
rare breed and he also brings a very
interesting contrarian view I would say
to the current kind of modus operandi or
the Zeitgeist in the community at the
moment he's a breath of fresh air anyway
um if you haven't already consider
subscribing uh to our YouTube channel or
indeed rating our podcast on your
favorite podcasting platform if you
happen to be listening to us so anyway
without any further delay I give you Dr
Walid Saba
[Music]
um welcome back to mlst folks
um we have the unmistakable War lead
suburb the uh the legend that has wanted
uh suburb but we also have mark from our
Discord community and uh mark would you
like to introduce yourself
hi guys hello I'm Mark godwell a
philosopher cognitive scientist and a
software engineer and big mlsd
right so hey awesome well welcome Mark
you know things have been a bit of a
blur but I think this is right Tim like
I think Walid was
you know the first or one of the first
really big names that
that we had come on the show right
um I I don't think so but the the most
controversial let's put it this way the
one that made uh probably
it was so predictable what what was I
mean
the probably the first one
broke that
uh
predictive model
well I just remember I mean I remember
Tim and I being like super because we
didn't know you right before before then
and I remember us being like so excited
that you agreed to uh come on the show
you know of course now that we know you
we're kind of like yeah whatever it's
just wallied but yeah like
that which is true we were following all
over ourselves that you were coming on
the show we're like oh my God this is so
awesome
to be honest with you I I never thought
I would I would
yeah I never thought I would have my
opinion would matter that much to be
honest with you and it it all started by
creating this medium blog and I started
spitting out stuff that
hey do you guys know that there's this
and this and that and I was surprised
how much it uh
even even by people that are
living off and making a living and they
preach and write papers on but I'm
attacking and they would say don't
mention my name by the way it's all
private messages
but apparently I I said a couple of
things that touched people but you know
yeah yeah and I was at in Europe's last
week and the amount of people that came
up to me and said I love the show Tim
what is my favorite guest that you've
had on because well he just provides a
completely different perspective right
because we're bred on empiricism and
neural networks and part of the reason I
want to get you back on Wally is to
counteract some of the uh I mean we've
been speaking to a lot of deep learning
people recently so so we need to we need
to counteract that um a little bit yeah
that one shot the hell out of me I mean
I I have people that like my stuff at
this event I mean
if you said ACL maybe yeah okay
but
I mean this is this is the Deep learning
meeting right I mean so I was shocked
but
yeah
yeah in days indeed although I have some
some some more positive views of DL now
oh come on
uh
yeah I mean look breaking news breaking
news
positive although I still have my
reservations as to AGI and all that
stuff but
I have been
completely impressed with the
developments in large language models I
have to admit that
sometimes I say what the hell is this
now technically let me tell you what's
happening uh
and I'm working on something that
probably would quantify
where can this go how much can you how
much will scale
the bottom line is this these guys have
impressed the hell out of me and they
have proven that scale does matter
I mean now these large language modeling
if you take language
from lexical to to syntactic to semantic
to pragmatic levels
they have definitely mastered syntax
and this is not a small feat I mean this
is huge
they have proven
that if I read
tons of text written by humans I can
figure out the grammar of language
and they have done that that's a huge
Okay so
and I don't like here where I don't like
people I don't want to mention names but
people that supposedly are in my Camp
right
insisting on refusing to see the
elephant in the room no
large language models have proven that
if I ingest
terabytes of text I will figure out
syntactic rules they have done that
now
uh okay and here's where technically uh
and you have to admit I mean you they uh
as a matter of fact they probably know
syntax now more than many college
graduates
okay these are from data that's a huge
experiment in cognitive science
that
no matter how how I mean you can't be
religious in this you have to be
scientific
I see the proof that these large
language models by ingesting tons of
text written by humans they have figured
out the syntax of language
end of story I I have there's an
existential proof go on open AI try
DaVinci to order DaVinci 3 or whatever
you like to try
there's syntactic
competency is beyond belief I'm shocked
every time I use it okay
now that's not the end of language
understand there's semantics and then
there's pragmatics wow I mean so
I'm working on something to quantify so
now we have I don't know we're up to a
trillion parameter
that allowed me to master syntax
now let's see semantics and semantic can
be broken down to
have you guys figured out reference
resolution have you guys figured out
scope resolution prepositional phrase
attachments
there are so many
uh pain points and semantic processing
can we quantify how many more parameters
we need to conquer semantics
and then pragmatics there are things
like
uh
the teenager shot a policeman and he
immediately fled away
now possibly both gangs the the he can
be the policeman
he fled away to escape further injuries
I mean that can happen
uh
but most likely the one that fled away
is the teenage
that's pragmatics because we know in the
world we live in if you shoot someone
they're gonna try to capture you
and you try to flee right that's not
semantics that's Way Beyond
how many parameters Beyond semantics do
you need to capture that
if you can put a
uh if you can come up with a rough
number I mean it could be a number
that's manageable that's doable buy more
scaling
which would be an interesting result but
it could be that it's a number Beyond
the universe we live in which means guys
except that you can Master syntax and a
little bit of lexical semantics you can
figure out the meaning of some words
but to do full understanding with
pragmatics
we're talking about numbers that
we might have to wait two thousand years
yes and Theory it works but so basically
I'm trying to work now on which is going
to be very difficult to quantify
because they have proven that scale
did improve syntax No Doubt not improve
it they've almost mastered some things
but how how far can this go quantity I
mean can you quantify how far can this
go scientifically without saying let's
try with more let's try with more which
is which is not it's not going to be
easy to do anyway
so I'm curious can I push back a little
bit on the the syntax she said if
they've mastered syntax and I'm kind of
okay I mean I guess you have an existing
proof and there's like a behavioral kind
of proof that it doesn't without very
syntactic sentences and obviously I've
learned something with whatever billions
of parameters but
but you say what those rules are could
we write them down probably not right
because it's a billion different numbers
of Weights no no actually okay you don't
have the old single kind of generative
grammar approach and also it's not the
way humans learn language and could you
reverse engineer or tweak it we don't
know what it is it's a black box so okay
there's a behavioral tense in which it
knows but but isn't it the way humans do
learn language I mean I I think it's
more though it's more related to the way
humans learn language than
I mean I I was
20 until I knew grammar
I mean we use language without without
knowing grammatical rules so so there is
an argument that humans don't know
grammar that it's you know pretty native
and all we do is tweak a few parameters
and then we add vocabulary over the
years and tweaks or whatever that's uh
you know the chomskin
um Jared of grammar approach
um so I don't think that we have a
billion parameters that we tweet over 20
years I don't think that's how we work
and we have I mean there's an amazing
competency of children at two years of
age you know what language they have
you've said you've started your writing
you've pointed this out actually
children know uh is absolutely amazing
you know straight out of you know excuse
me it is amazing but
it is amazing and I and I didn't change
the way I think about it and we have
innate stuff
but
here's the change that these guys have
made me
uh go through it's a minor change but
it's it's it's not that subtle actually
here's the thing
I was told before these new results are
coming out but look we do have innate
stuff which
took us
three four hundred thousand years of
evolution
all we're doing by ingesting all this
text is we're simulating right these 300
000 years
so
give us a chance
to simulate this innateness if you want
in a way in a way
uh
okay I I that argument was said a long
time ago and I thought come on you're
chasing infinite
what how was it the real difference
in my mind now is they have proven that
they conquered one beast in language
nobody can dispute that
can I have a go at disputing it so um in
the um collision and photo connectionism
critique they spoke about productivity
you know the infinite cardinality of of
language there was recently a deep mind
paper talking about the Chomsky
hierarchy and uh deep neural network
where I mean rnns are regular languages
but you know I think Transformers and
the rest of them are at the bottom of
the hierarchy so quantitatively we know
we haven't conquered Infinity so why
with such a a shallow Horizon are they
doing so well I agree here's here's the
thing language use
languages infinite
but probably the long tail of uh
probably 90 percent of ordinary language
use
right can be figured out from the stuff
that we write
so
they will never capture all of language
yes
but they might reach the level of of a
competent educated man Like Us in
language competency
well so what all I'm saying is what they
have achieved is a huge
uh result
in terms of the big question of scale
and Big Data
they have definitely proved
that if I see enough data I will learn
something and something that's not
trivial
look I'm you know where I'm coming from
you're talking voter and pilotion I mean
you're preaching to the choir right but
but but I have to be a scientist too I
mean I I don't like I'm following Gary
Marcus and he's like he I don't like
people that minimize what happened
like I'm a scientist right I see a big
result I say wow right yeah and look
we're talking nobody best deep learning
more than me especially large language
models I mean I'm like uh I was saying
this is silly right but I have to stay I
have to say
they have proven something to me at
least
which is huge because I know how how
difficult language is I am impressed
equally
wouldn't you say it's an engineering an
engineering Triumph rather than
scientific
it's an engineering Triumph but here's
the point mark I think it's a little bit
more
that's the only thing I'm trying to I'm
not saying look I didn't give up on I
can get to the criticism later so don't
put me on in that camp yet right or or
else right because I know I know
theoretically theoretically
mathematically
you cannot understand language this way
all I'm saying is
in terms of cognitive science what
happened and what is happening as we
speak
is not nothing it's a huge
but for example if I can ingest a lot
again what they proved is the world two
are related so it's one thing scale
from tons and tons of data I can learn
something that is not trivial that to me
has been proven
the point I'm making is not the point
I'm making is not that they solve the
language problem sorry go ahead I want
to jump in here a little bit because um
from my perspective I think
part of why
you're saying it's it's huge is because
I think it was a huge step for you
personally because I know you know from
the past like talking to you like you've
had a much more extreme View
um you know on the capabilities of large
language models then for example myself
because for me like
I don't see anything new here it's kind
of like like I'll give you an example
outside of um of syntax just for a
moment so just um transcription because
that's what like Tim and I happen to be
working on quite a bit right now right
like in other words transcribing audio
into text okay
uh all the state of the art you know
models are pretty much sitting around
each other at about 90 percent you know
accuracy right of transcription but but
here's the thing is that's for
people speaking
relatively common languages with a
relatively standard accent okay as soon
as you as soon as you bring someone in
the room that has an accent or speaks a
you know
um with maybe like um some type of a
challenge like a speech challenge or or
this that the other thing it becomes
garbage again and like for at least if
you introduce noise or over right or or
there's noise in the background music
playing in the background and as as Tim
and I have probably hammered you know to
death and beaten a dead horse on our
Channel like so many times we've never
doubted that machine learning can learn
like the bulk of the curve where it
really really struggles is in all these
edge cases and the in the in the corner
cases and the in the periphery where it
can you know easily it's very brittle
right and those those kind of areas like
this is the point we've been making out
for a long long time and so the fact
that like
massive trillions of parameters and
terabytes of data was able to learn 90
or more 95 or whatever as syntax
okay I get it like from from a linguist
perspective that was a you know maybe a
big Triumph or something but I'm still
always about that other like five
percent and the problem with the
approach of deep neural networks is to
get that other five percent is like
100 times as many more parameters
whereas like using words using more
generalized abstracted you know methods
that we haven't yet you're hitting it on
the nail and that's why I'm working out
on quantifying this because
now we are doing exponential growth in
the uh number of parameters for not even
linear growth in the accuracy even
logarithmic I agree with you 100 so that
other 10 percent might require
uh 2000 years of data that we don't even
have that's what I'm working on how far
can this go because the function
is against them now like uh I mean we're
increasing GPU power and the number of
data that we're ingesting exponentially
for a minute
uh increase in accuracy which is right
less than the logarithmic and this is
this is part of the analysis that we
have to go through so look I all my
reservations that I had before apply so
don't I'm being misunderstood all I'm
saying is simple
these guys what they have done is not as
trivial as I thought initially okay so
let me let me really
be very careful and what I'm saying
because now I have a following I don't
want to lose it uh
it no I'm I'm not I'm not changing
scientifically where I was I mean
science is science and I know
theoretically I don't get into things
like intentionality and these models
understand nothing about the world I'm
talking about syntax only by the way
syntax on
and some coherence when they patch
things together
the coherence is amazing they're not
patching things together that don't
relate at all
so I'm talking about syntax and and
coherence and symptoms okay and a touch
of semantics right
my point let me repeat it so that I'm
not misunderstood
they have proven something that many
cognitive scientists
would never accept never ever
but this existential proof
has told many cognitive scientists don't
dismiss learning from data only blind no
labeling
some aspects of language
actually very impressive aspects of
language
these guys have proven that
and me as a cognitive scientist I have
to admit because I see it
I see
from data alone these systems have
learned non-trivial aspects of language
now
how do you
interpret that where do you take it what
do you conclude from it we can we can
debate that but all I'm saying is I have
seen
something that I never thought I would
see that just ingesting text
and these deep Networks
you can actually figure something not
trivial about language that has been
done
I mean
you can you can say there are pigs pigs
that fly okay
prove me wrong I saw them prove they
don't exist well I can't but
existential proofs are the most powerful
proofs
it's an existential proof proof by doing
I'm showing you language competency by
ingesting text only
so this dismissive
uh
that all these are uh what
what is the phrase that Melanie uses not
Melania
stochastic parrots no oh Bender Emily
Bender Emily
no these are not stochastic parrots
anymore for me I am seeing look if I go
through the tests on conducting I have
20 pages of tests on every aspect
uh and they get better I mean I am
seeing things that
um lexical ambiguity the warm is
resolved like uh
uh
we were at the baseball stadium last
night we had a ball
they knew that ball is not the baseball
I'm seeing things like what the hell is
this right and and if anybody can test
these systems I can with all humility
I'm trying my best now to make them fail
which was not the case just a month ago
all I'm saying is I'm seeing something
that I never thought I would see
as a cognitive scientist as a
computational linguist
let me put it this way to see to see
this capability now
you have to bring back Montague
freely
Marvin Minsky John McCarthy
all the pioneers of logic and AI put
them together and give them
a thousand bright engineer and they will
not do this
in a minute we're going to get on to
your book review but you are just
alluding to the problem of semantics and
pragmatics and also I want to bring in
simple grounding as being the next
potential brick walls could you just
talk to that a little bit more well look
simple grounding was an issue in
symbolic systems
you're using symbolic uh systems so
you're saying cats
cat
it's reference based semantics so I'm
gonna use cat to refer to a concept
called cat
and then the concept called cat is a
frame in most systems and frame-based
systems with properties it's a mammal
it's a thing that has this and this kind
of fair whiskers blah blah blah
it's the intention of what a cat is and
then simple grounding came like okay
you're defining cat a symbol in terms of
symbols
like so where do we go it's like a it's
like a dictionary to to read the
definition of a word I have to know all
the words so I might go and so it's a
cyclical
representational system it's not
grounded in anything in the end it's a
close basically it's a system that
defines itself like what the hell is
going on here right
simple grounding was
cat has to be associated with something
real outside that's a real cat in
symbolic systems we don't have that
right
we can get into simple grounding uh it's
a it's a Phu it's a huge subject on its
own like word meanings
where the words get their meaning from
right uh is it uh embodied is it
experiential does it have to be
um
can can a deaf earn a blind person ever
understand the meaning of something so
that that's a huge or is it yeah I mean
we spoke to Andrew lampinen and and he
was getting into Pierce's Triad
semiotics you know this embodied
relativistic notion of of grounding
which actually I'm I'm developing a bit
of a taste for personally but you're
very skeptical about that could you just
sketch that out I I don't think that's
the issue grounding I mean people make
make a lot of it and like our common
friend Bishop Mark Bishop
that you will never understand the
meaning of something if you don't live
in the environment and it's a
that has never been I don't believe so
that's why we call it artificial
intelligence right I mean uh we're never
going to have the intelligence of a
human being we're never going to have a
robot that really chokes when they see
uh their nephew after six years right I
mean and that's that was never the one
that's why we're building artificial
intelligence not a human intelligence so
this whole argument about
grounding and embodiment and I will
never understand what pain is because a
robot will never really feel pain that
to me that's besides the point I'm not
building artificial life I'm building an
artificially intelligent machine that
will do things in a way that you will
say what the hell was that
probably that's how I should be defined
that's it
what uh who did this right that's it it
feels pain or it doesn't feel pain or it
will never know what what crying is like
so so
at least I I come from this angle I I'm
not into
building artificial humans I'm an
engineer I'm into building artificial
intelligence systems that can reason
right uh in the environment we live in
solve problems intelligently and
problems that usually require human
intelligence like I'm into I would like
to see a world where we don't have
accountants come
we don't have doctors I I open my mobile
I have a doctor I converse with them
intelligently and they tell me exactly
what to do done
nobody goes to medical school anymore
everybody should write poetry and play
music and enjoy the beach that's it
that's the AI I'm interested in we will
never build robots that will understand
uh love so
so
to me these are arguments that
there are relevant we're building
artificial intelligence when we did
calculators we never gave a damn how we
do it in the mind and we have
calculators that can beat
any mathematician and doing uh division
of two prime numbers Each of which is 20
digits yeah I think it's it's more where
your area of interest is I mean so yours
is in the engineering and you know
what's what's coming to mind right now
is um our conversation with Professor
Chomsky where he said you know like yeah
these are these are great feats of
engineering you know I mean I I like
bulldozers too they just don't have
anything to do with science right like
so I mean sure like or philosophy you
know for that matter so I mean I think
some of these questions
yeah maybe they don't have a lot to do
with building AIS that do a bunch of
useful things but but they have a lot to
do with philosophy or science or you
know whatever mathematics you know for
that matter you know this is a bridge to
the book because
the the uh the authors were
misunderstood from their title and I
told them that privately
no not privately I I want to tell them
that because
I got comments from people privately
that the title is misleading the title
assumes they are anti-ai none really
they're saying roughly what I'm saying
I'm not interested in building an
artificial human we can never do that
probably
right so all this and this is important
because people are
trivializing I mean you have people
talking about AGI from five years ago
and all we had was something that can do
amazing pattern recognition that's it so
it's important for us to say hey guys
cool it down do you know what we what
you mean when you talk or machines that
surpass human intelligence
this is this is not just a word you
throw out because you're impressed with
A system that can recognize cats from
dogs come on take it easy slow down
right
and this book is about that it's like do
you know what it means to have a system
that can
feel and uh and react instantly real
time to changing situations around them
and do you know what you're talking
about so
so yeah I'm interested in the
engineering side of AI and that's what
makes me impressed by something like
a da Vinci to what division III as
as an as an AI
Enthusiast I look at this and I say wow
we've never been able to reach this
milestone
this is a huge milestone that's how I
look at it
will it be will it be the solution for
the language understanding problem no
because language understanding in the
full sense of the word understanding
the way we speak now the way we were
speaking now involves a lot more than
mastering symptoms but
but they did Master a big aspect of
language
and I can see it I can try it and I'm
trying to make it fail now in syntax and
even some coherence some mild let's call
them mild semantics
uh and it's very impressive
so
uh the question now becomes for
AI researchers not just Engineers it
is this uh
is this scalability scalable is this
scalable will is this approach scale
so much data and so much compute power
they mastered syntax more or less I
think they did at least as much as a
competent
language user
so my first question is like do you see
natural language as essentially
computable as in like turing machine
computer or do we need some other kind
of new mathematics to describe it for
example hyper computation whenever that
might be in other words is there a
generative grammar or algorithm or a set
of rule that generates our valid
sentences
uh when it comes to language itself I
think language is a foreign language
there is a
there is a compiler for natural language
that can be built like we have built one
for Java C sharp
all right so this is Montague yeah uh
yeah I I believe Montague was right
although Montague was was attacking the
semantics part
okay he touched a little bit on
intention and then not much on
pragmatics but Montague and it took me
years and I had to be advised by a very
smart philosopher logician that stopped
saying Montague didn't deal with this
Montague was never in the business of
reference resolution that's pragmatics
Montague was trying to prove
there is a formal system and algebraic
system and he used Lambda calculator
strongly typed system that I can use to
compose language like I do with
arithmetic or calculus sorry there's a
logic there's a mathematics for language
which is a huge thing Montague was not a
trivial
uh semanticist in the history of
language he was huge or would you say
that Montague is did for language some
ethics of language what chance do you
did for syntax of language exactly
exactly and and the common uh
denominator into sleep between them is
someone that Chomsky himself admires a
lot Barbara party
who was uh he she did her PhD with
Montague she's a Montague Montague
semantics
but she and she she did say almost the
same phrase he said what Montague did
for semantics is equivalent to what
chance created for syntax yes okay
exactly almost exact phrase yeah
but you think he was right about
semantics yeah so for example there's a
computable definition of what is a pile
of sand right
no no see I'm like I'm not sure you're
right about that no no hold on let's not
get Montague was not a like
psychographer or an ontologist or a he
said whatever your meaning for something
is okay he didn't even care Montague
never did Anthology and conceptual and
like what how do you define the meaning
of what is a book
look let's and it took me I I'm telling
you it took me three years to appreciate
what Montague was doing and my thesis
was on Montague cement the the Masters
before the PHD here's what Montague did
uh Keith and you'll appreciate
Montague said whatever your meaning for
the individual words the lexical meaning
so cat means C okay you go with your
psychologist and and cognitive
scientists and ontologists and disagree
about the meaning of a cat
finally you come to me and you say we
have a meaning for cat and it's c
you're following me Montague never cared
about what is the nature of things
outside right
whatever your meaning for these
individual concepts are
right
here's how you make you get the meaning
of a whole
mathematically
I'll give you a simple example that will
make you appreciate what I'm talking
about
uh John refers to a person right
the The Neighbor Next Door
refers to a person
The Neighbor Next Door that just moved
from California refers to a person
The Neighbor Next Door that knows John
very well and and drives a Ford LTD as a
person
all of how can you have this phrase and
John refer to a person and have the same
semantic type compositional
in a way that never fails
like you do in arithmetic he wanted to
prove that natural language is a formal
language
he developed a semantic algebra that
makes this long phrase refer to the in
the end to an object that has the same
semantic type as John mathematically if
you do it it never fails
the details of this were genius
okay so Montague
then made the big claim
natural language is a formal language
give me some time I'll work out the full
algebra
you go then and decide what the
individual meanings are I don't care
Montague never gave a damn about
cognitive science or and and knowledge
and and he was a logician he wanted to
prove there's a calculus underneath
naturally
calculus of meanings you decide on the
meaning
I'm telling you it took me a while I
thought he's doing semantics what is the
meaning of this in mind because he said
he never cared
he was doing an algebra of meanings
regardless of what the meanings are
okay so but
but his project was
huge I don't think he was trying to
prove
there's a
there's a there's an algebraic system
behind language
like any other form of language like you
can get an arithmetic expression and
build a tree for that evaluate it and
get the final meaning natural language
works the same way except it's not that
simple that's all so
his project was huge and he was
misunderstood yeah
so he was really doing semantics
right that's semantics pragmatics is a
different thing
what do you think is the the core unique
property of natural human language would
you agree with Chomsky on it being
digital Infinity
uh yeah uh okay the infinite thing in
the productivity uh
to me no it's uh
I'm half a chomskin have something else
to me no the the real real unique thing
about language
and that's why even if Montague
succeeded that's half the battle
it's not in the semantics although
that's huge
to me it's the
pragmatic side the abductive influence I
mean we
uh we use induction and we use deduction
and we always ignore abduction abduction
is the unique is the
humanly unique reasoning capability I
mean the rats do inductive reasons they
they to a certain extent that's how they
learn few things inductively really
um all the lower species do inductive
reasoning to a certain extent
uh and some of them do some deductive
reasoning if this than this but at a
very shallow level of course
abductive reasoning is uniquely human
and that's the part of language
understanding right
uh which means reasoning to the best
explanation abductive reasoning is I
reach a conclusion not inductively
by
induction or and not deductively I
deduced it but I reached this conclusion
because it's possible it can happen
and it is the best conclusion I can come
up with given everything else I know
objective reasoning is the real
reasoning methodology that makes us
unique as human
we reason to the best we reason it's
called reasoning to the best explanation
right so that's that's
Pierce and uh others I mean Pierce was
the pioneer of abductive reasoning or
abduction
but I'm talking about and abduction has
come to have two sort of tracks and
there's abductive reasoning in in the
traditional philosophical charts peers
but there's abductive reasoning as
uh it used to be called in the 80s on
case-based reasoning came out and
expert systems
there was something called ebl
explanation based learning and it was
even a learning technique which is
really reasoning
to the best explanation basically
I have to make a decision actually uh
Jerry Hobbs you guys heard me mention
his name several times before
who's I think huge in semantics
uh has a paper when he was at SRI with
other luminaries too the title is
interpretation as abduction or
understanding as abduction and basically
he shows how all the difficult
all the challenges in language
understanding Beyond semantics so we're
done with Montague now I'm doing the
final understanding of what makes sense
given because every expression has
several meanings even if I did the
semantics perfectly I have to choose the
most plausible meaning from all the
possible meanings that's pragmatics and
the way you do that very well is in
language we do abductive reasoning we
say I I'm left with three meanings three
possible syntax excluded
200 syntax trees semantics excluded few
invalid uh semantic expressions and I'm
left with three still three possible
meanings they can all happen in the word
we live in which one is the most
plausible we do this abductively which
meaning is the most likely meaning given
the context and what I know
that's the last challenging language
so we need to we need to add the
objective model which we humans do I go
back to the teenager policeman
both meanings both interpretation can
happen right
either one can flee right but most
likely it's the teenager that fled away
given what I know and given that's
abductive reasoning but semantically
both can happen
yes I do want to emphasize something
that Wally like briefly mentioned but I
think it's very important to mention is
that there's two senses of abduction
okay and and they they differ in the
following way which is like kind of the
more modern sense which is what Wally's
been talking about like pretty much this
whole time is abduction used to justify
hypotheses right okay but the older and
original sense of it and still an
equally important one is abduction for
generating
hypotheses and this this like ability to
generate hypotheses is something that's
extremely powerful and you know so far
unique
hold on let me just let me just finish
here which is this like this is like
something where Einstein is just sitting
there pontificating on like you know
how the heck can light be the same no
matter how the Earth is moving and blah
blah blah and comes up with out of thin
air okay like this hypothesis that you
know
that uh that that relativity applies
right that the physical laws are the
same no matter what your what your
reference frame is so that ability to
like this ability to almost that people
talk about
sort of pull from thin air this kind of
intuitive leap to something that's that
ends up being like a gray you know brand
new Theory that's also
um abduction right but in both cases
Keith and I agree with you that's uh
the old view of what abduction abductive
reasoning was to scientists but in both
cases you're choosing from possible
oh no no no just just a minute because
this is where I I think I probably quite
disagree with you which is the modern
sense of abduction to me is much more
similar to just inference like to a
Bayesian so in other words you give me a
whole slew of hypotheses and I can tell
you which hypotheses should be preferred
you know just on the basis of
marginalization and strict like Bayesian
Theory no problem with that it's not
actually abduction it's just you know
inference right it's just rules events
whereas whereas just a minute
generating that that space in the first
place is unique and very different from
inference like the ability to produce
you know from nothing models to consider
that's the core of abduction from my
point of view
but okay so we're saying the same thing
but in different these possibilities
that you generate
are valid possibilities so abductive
reasoning I don't know if they're valid
until I do the inference
no no you're generating a pool of
possibilities that's the step generating
a pull flying possibility fine but but
in there
teeth I think we're saying the same
thing it's just the terminology in the
end you're choosing from a set of
possible
valid hypothesis
induction is you don't know where you're
going
until you get there
in abductive reasoning you are
whether it's the old way or the or the
Modern Way in the end what's common
between them is I have a set of
possibilities I will I will use
abductive reasoning to decide which is
the most plausible in a sense you're
scoring them and you're saying from all
these possibilities this is the most
plausible yeah yeah but see you keep
assuming the you keep positing that you
have a bunch of possibilities and I'm
saying those possibilities have to come
from somewhere and where they come from
is abduction oh oh okay it depends on
the domain and language they come from
what we know is true okay okay I see
your point but where they come from
depends on the domain of reasoning so in
many cases they come from
uh what we know is true like uh or they
come from evidence or okay I agree yeah
I guess I guess it's just important to
know there are these two senses of
abduction and um and don't forget about
both of them because they're both right
and that's why that's why abduction uh
like induction
as opposed to deduction abduction and
induction are both approximate you can
never have 100 because in the end you're
assigning a score you're saying so both
of them are are probabilistic in a way
or or they have a certain uncertainty
so when you're doing abductive reasoning
even in language I I make a decision as
this is the right interpretation given
the context but it's uh what we call
could be wrong you might have eaten a
ball and that's why when I read further
I change my further my first
interpretation uh so we have so in in
language is not monotonic actually we do
non-monatonic reasoning and in the sense
that I might override my first decision
so so but all all of that is pragmatics
and we and we do this in conversation I
uh two three sentences after I
understand really fully what you said
before because I I remade the
interpretation
do you have any any thoughts on where
where this came from or or basically the
evolution of language or if you like the
evolution of this abductive athlete you
have do you have any ideas or you know
is it unique to humans it seems that
it's uh you know what are you oh unique
to humans definitely definitely I mean
animal language animal symbolic
languages have been studied thoroughly
and
two things here's where the genius of
folder comes in productivity I mean
language have a finite set of symbols
and they're not productive they don't do
compositions
uh uh and this ties to it this is
animals your timeout
no animal no no non-human animal
has a productive language in other words
I have a set of symbols and if I can
compose them I I can make a new symbol
language animals don't compose things
because they don't decompose them when
they're they have a finite it's a hash
table if I make this symbol I mean this
if I make this okay no matter how
sophisticated it is
because they don't have recursion they
don't have Infinity they can't deal at
that level with complexity some of them
have a larger lexicon than others okay
but that's still the same paradigm
so productivity in other words this
capacity to learn
we were just talking about John or
The Neighbor Next Door or
The Neighbor Next Door that just came
from California I can I can productively
make a person out of three sentences and
in the end they collapse to add John
right that productivity doesn't exist in
any species except to humans which means
compositionality which means
systematicity which means all of that so
it's Unique to human definitely this has
been established and it came with
thoughts that's the if and only if
that's why we're the only species that
really reason I mean okay I have people
insist that animals think and they
reason
they're not really reasoning okay only
humans reason and thought and language
came together it's sort of like if and
only if
there are some there's some proof even
anthropologists and uh
they say it looks like uh language was
detected when tools and uh and some
basic Machinery was detected first so
the the human mind at some point had
this
capacity to think and language came with
it it was like almost at the same time
so it's uniquely human definitely now
where did it come from
wow
um
I I think it was the
uh
the need really to express thoughts like
at some point we started having thoughts
that we want to communicate
so the external artifact we see outside
whether it's English or or ancient Greek
or Latin one
and languages evolve for societal reason
and all that but but the external
artifact that we use to communicate
thoughts
came out of the need of the internal
language that started to develop what
are called the language of thought
mentalese
and we so we had that thing going on
inside and then we had to communicate we
started with weird sounds and then we
scribbled things on the wall to
communicate and then that thing
developed until we started
making symbols like okay if I say this
that means this
I don't know the exact process I'm not a
biologist or evolutionary linguist or
but I think thought is the key so
there's a language of thought
and these external things aren't because
linguistic research has also shown that
there are many universals in language
regardless of what the language is even
if they are completely different systems
like Asian languages and and Latin based
languages they all have
a verb an action
they all have objects and agents of the
action
they all have events and events have
duration time and place
so that there are a set of cognitive I
call them Universal cognitive Primitives
right
there's always an objects there
somewhere or an agent of an activity
now how you express it in different
languages besides these are universals
that's
that's the language of thought that's
the internal language which has to be
the same
uh and objects have properties and all
that so there are Universal Primitives
and we
instantiate them in different languages
differently but that's
to me secondary okay okay that's great
um could you talk a little bit about
your your recent property
the colleague
that I never worked with but a colleague
in in
the field uh to review this book and I
looked at it and I said oh
I have enough on my plate this is not an
easy book
um
but then I uh because I liked it I said
yeah I'd like to write it and in the end
it turned out to be not as
technically involved as I thought it's
sort of
and I'm saying that not to to be
negative but it's sort of the same
argument over and over the gist of the
argument is quite simple actually
and they try to prove it from different
Vantage points than in the book from a
biological sociological psychological
mathematical
but the gist of the book is
any talk of AGI is Wishful thing and
it's beyond anything we can ever develop
mathematically so as to engineer it in
any
in any realistic way
they make good arguments throughout
there are many examples of the the basic
idea is that
uh
all the mathematics we know right the
mathematics available to us
cannot model
not just the entire mind but even
subsystems in the mind
language being one of them
uh and so it's all complex systems
within complex systems in a complex
environment the system around us
that we interact with and none of it can
be modeled mathematically none of it
even at any level
so forget doing AGI that can interact
with us in an intelligent way
now you can do control narrow AI
right you can build very intelligent
machines that can do amazing stuff
but any talk of AGI strong AI
is just stuck until unless and they
admit that unless
we come up with a new mathematics that
we never even knew at at the scale of
leibniz calculus or or Newton like we're
talking about a new mathematics that we
never conceived of right
which they say most likely all evidence
says
that's not going to happen right so
now you can get into why
so that's their claim and why they they
say that all these systems are complex
systems and in complex systems the the
idea is that
these are
first of all Dynamic systems they work
in a dynamic environment
they are
continuously evolving and adapting right
they are
self-feeding systems these are not
systems that only take input output
these systems change their behavior and
I gave an example from list
these systems are systems that change
their behavior their algorithms if you
want they change their mind
from a stimulus so I might and that's
why I said they I I would have liked to
see a discussion on the frame problem
because the frame problem in the eye is
about this how can I reason
in a dynamic and uncertain environment
and react dynamically although what I do
in the environment might affect what I
believe about the environment in real
time
and they're right there is no
mathematics we know of now that's why we
don't have a solution for the frame
problem
so
this kind of cyclical cause and effect
cannot be modeled by anything going on
mathematics and this I agree with that
uh they they give an example if I made
just an example in language for example
language we know if I have a dialogue
uh okay we all agree that the
interpretation of any utterance requires
having the context in mind as as part of
the part of the input to the evaluation
of the meaning is the context as an
extra parameter right
now the context is changing based on
something I cannot predict which is
the response to uh of of some
participant in the dialogue there is no
meaningful way of predicting
how someone might respond
so in other words the context is
mathematically not defined but I needed
an interpretation thus no language
understanding no language understanding
no AGI because they believe language
understanding is a prerequisite so the
the
conclusion
and you can question every step in this
inference they come to but they give
language as an example but we have
social behavior I can give an example
they have a nice example and
social behavior here's an example of a
complex system that cannot you know we
don't have any mathematics that can
model
we're staying in a queue and a
a clinic an emergency room
what do they call them these ER
so but there's a cue because they all
have emergencies right
now the
social behave then the social Norm is
that in the queue okay we all we all
have urgent issues but in the end I came
first right okay so that's a social
no
and but can a robot understand
that if someone fainted
really spiritually I mean he is almost
gone right
our social Norm accepts that this person
uh violates the cue
order
right this is something Dynamic that
happens like God the cue is this way
and how can a robot update the rules and
not kill someone because they violated
the the order of the
in other words these interactions these
cyclical cause and effect are very
complex that no mathematical model
or the example I I said in language they
prove this cannot be done context is
needed to interpret everything I cannot
predict what the context will be because
I cannot predict you respond to my
so it's unpredictable they call it
erratic almost random so there is no
mathematics that can model it
and there are many aspects to the Mind
whether it's social reasoning language
and then and then they conclude
there cannot be
A system that we can model on volume and
machines
because we don't have the mathematics to
model it and these they go into deep
learning
and they give examples even like deep
learning no matter how much data you
ingest you can never predict the future
you're lucky if you can do a good job on
the past
and even forget the future
and definitely forget the uh sorry the
present
because I have a couple comments so um
uh one is um would you agree that this
is um quite synonymous with you know
Douglas Hofstadter's strange strange
loops and the whole like around a
reference to self-referential systems
because I mean complex system is a big
part of them is they usually are they do
have feedback loops and at some scale
they become so they will involve
self-reference yeah yeah okay
um my other another point I want to make
is um this you know I I have quite a bit
of sympathy towards the Viewpoint right
of this of this book that you're talking
about with one exception which is I'm
still optimistic that we can discover a
mathematics that may help us out and so
I always think to um the foundation
series by Isaac Asimov because in there
they discover a science and a
mathematics called psycho history which
at least allows them to predict complex
systems of a certain scale and larger so
in the book it's sort of like Planet
scale and larger they're able to
actually predict you know of these
complex sociological systems and human
behaviors and how they're going to
interact like beyond beyond that scale
and it's really fast I make that point I
highly recommend that series to anybody
because it's very fascinating because
um you know they talk a lot about sort
of what if you had the science what
might it look like Etc and in there
there's like this little tiny
microscopic thing that's beyond the
predictability of of psycho history that
comes in and kind of mucks up the works
and and creates anomalies that they have
to constantly keep combating against so
right I think if anybody wants a
fictional take on on a possible
mathematics of this like I would
recommend yeah
I say I agree with that argument we're
trying to model complex systems in the
sense of uh cyclical cause and effective
we don't have anything that can model
them intelligently and I give an example
in this in this I can write the program
that changes itself at runtime because
lisp is intentional I can the whole
program can be a parameter which I can
look at it okay code is data that's all
this data and I can manipulate the
program itself and go look at it after
execution and see a different program
than the one I wrote it's it's amazing
this
so if I so I can write programs in this
that no one can understand
and model and do program verification
so I make the argument that okay I can
see your point
but like Keith said
never is a long time why say we cannot
come up with a new mathematics I can see
you at one point someone discovering
yeah at the level of Newton differential
calculus why not which could happen so
the word never for me
uh it's hard to digest maybe an AGI will
discover the mathematics to create
itself
and the other Point autopyetic Energy
the other point is which is another
point that John McCarthy wants who said
we have to understand what we built
here's what I mean do we understand
ourselves we don't
so why not build a scary intelligent
machine that we don't really understand
like my list program so what I'm saying
is I had I had an issue with them saying
that precludes AGI no it doesn't in
theory
I can build a complex intelligent
machine like us in many respects
doesn't feel pain hey who cares but it's
scaringly intelligent
and we don't understand how it works so
what this can happen I can build
something I don't understand
so in theory I have two issues with with
their book
that this never and this absolute
decision that we're done we can never
get there no we might build something we
don't understand
by discovering some new weird
mathematics so okay I agree with you
that it's a it's a complex thing that we
will never understand but so
but what I loved about the book is it's
a sobering book I mean
it really is a balancing book compared
to the hype and the Simplicity you see
out there I mean you you so you'd
recommend it
or highly because okay I mean I didn't
need that much sobering I know that any
talk of AGI is like hey take a break
enjoy your paycheck but don't make silly
statements like this right okay although
I felt I thought you might have fallen
off that wagon at the beginning of this
conversation I'm defend I'm a defender
of the faith but but uh so it's I
recommend it to people that need it like
me I needed it too it's a sobering book
like this is how complex what you're
trying to do is okay guys so before you
go out and say
language understand and and the nice
thing is they took aspects of the mind
just language itself is a beast that we
cannot conquer
so imagine the whole mind and and the
granular thing they go through it I mean
it's all it's complex systems all the
way down or all the way up if you want
so
uh language is a complex system on its
own part of the mind which is a complex
system on its own part of the human
living organism which is a complex
system on its own so it and at every
level the complexity
we don't have a mathematics for it
that's the gist of their argument so
people that make these big claims about
AI need to read it guys cool down
cool down you you have not solved
problems that occupy the most
penetrating Minds in the history of
enemy from Emmanuel Khan to you have not
solved these problems cool it down
you can build narrow AI
very narrow AI
and all this transfability
transferability I mean if you're good at
just I know people that are good at
chess and they're almost good at nothing
else not okay so
forget this if I'm good at chess
I can be a smart doctor no
so we are a very complex machine so this
book is a good sobering book
mathematically speaking philosophically
speaking so that people will tone down
what they're saying
and start speaking science instead of
media gibberish right
deep learning will soon be able to do
everything I mean from a scientist
it seems like a council of Despair
almost is there any optimistic or or
positive hopeful aspects to it
no I that part I don't like just never
right I mean I I am a believer that we
can do AGI
really
but not a human like AI
we might do
uh
a very powerful AI that in many ways is
more I mean we we've done that now I
mean machines are now Superior to us in
many respects and respects even that
they require intelligence not a
bulldozer that can lift more than me uh
that will have to do cognitive tasks
better than us we have go
right or uh
or finding patterns and data at a scale
that no human can do so
so we are building intelligent machines
but
can we conquer things like language like
autonomous driving was a failure it's a
big upset for AI because they trivialize
the problem right we can go yeah uh well
that and that's kind of what I wanted to
get to you know Mark kind of in response
to you which is um
I take these kind of sobering these
sobering things and and look I mean
I I the book sounds great and I'm
definitely gonna get it and and read it
but some of these these thoughts you
know many people have had
you know many times over the years right
and have recognized that there are these
limitations but I think like part of
part of why I think books like this are
actually have an optimistic kind of side
to them is I hope I hope they encourage
people to get more creative okay like
like stop just trying to dump every
single dollar you have into yet another
parameter you know and to get another
thousand or billion parameters in a
model like let's take some of our
resources like sure let's keep doing
that engineering but let's take some
portion of our resources here and invest
it in like crazy ideas and I know
because it's like they make like Kenneth
Kenneth Stanley kind of type thing right
like just go out there and try to do
something crazy to to find that
mathematics that we need right which is
let's get creative let's work on crazy
things let's have crazy ideas let's work
on hybrid systems let's not give up on
you know um
um neuromorphic you know systems and
computer or whatever like let's spread
out let's spread out a bit
um because of the fact that if we just
keep going down this direction of ever
larger Turing machines
like that may not be the solution right
actually so they make this point exactly
in different ways that if anything their
goal is to let people widen their
Horizon yeah there's so many aspects of
this problem that guys if if we keep
going this is not going to get us there
and that's why they argued
mathematically philosophically and I
think they have a good argument this is
not going to take us there but let's
explore that's that's so that and being
so religious about this will will hinder
any other possibility so
all overall their argument is a good
argument I think everybody should read
this book uh that's interested in AGI as
a goal uh what we have cannot ever take
us there they prove this mathematically
I mean to me they proved it in language
only
so we need something new and if you want
to do something new we can't just stay
in this corner and with this that's not
going to get us there so in a way it's
not a negative book
it's a sobering book I will use the term
sober well and an encouraging of more
variety and more daring and more
creativity and right they don't push too
much on that but but indirectly the the
indirect
net result if people appreciate the
argument will be to look
and explore other ways so
in a way it's more positive than
negative and by the way stating a
mathematical fact is never negative
[Music]
for stating like mathematical facts so
careful yeah but I mean if they're
saying that
what we're doing now would not would
never get us to AGI that's not negative
I mean you're saying we need something
else we need something more or you're
look it could have saved us they use
this phrase money down the drain
autonomous driving is a case is a good
case yeah billions we're talking
non-trivial money guys we're talking
more than the budgets of some European
countries
did you just imagine the scale you know
and and those guys went busts right
why because they trivialized the
autonomous an autonomous car is an
autonomous agent guys
it's an it's an agent trying to reason
in a dynamic and uncertain environment
and has on the fly to change to do
belief revision change its strategy
because of something new that came up
all of that is from seeing the tree and
the stop sign
it's all vision
yeah so that's actually encouraging
because now for all the Uber drivers out
there and long-haul truck drivers your
your job is safe like it's it's it's not
going to be replaced anytime soon yeah
it's amazing and a few years back when I
was still in the valley
yeah I was in Mecca in Silicon Valley
and I would talk to superb phds and
Neuroscience and big AI engineers at top
companies
they were so excited that we're at level
four in a year or two and this was six
years ago I say guys this will not
happen they say why you're so negative I
said you cannot have an autonomous agent
on the road without solving the frame
problem how do I revise everything I
know because of this new event
and this has to happen real time
we don't have a solution for the frame
problem all you're doing is you have
cars on a railway we have autonomous
cars now it's called It's called The
Train
the person we have autonomous flight
that's a good point if I'm not in a
dynamic and uncertain environment
reasoning yeah I can have autonomous
anything so
we call it the railway I mean
we call it Anthrax it's autonomous you
press a button and it goes
if we're talking about reasoning in the
Streets of San Francisco
you have to face the frame problem or
you will kill people
anyway
on that sobering note you know uh yeah I
think a lot of stuff goes unnoticed in
San Francisco so I'm not sure about that
yeah probably that's the least of those
cars of money that went the skate this
is the value of this book the scale of
investment I mean if 10 of that was put
on another approach hey you weird guy
with this weird idea uh take ten percent
of what we're throwing down the drain
and explore something else so
wasting billions of dollars just because
I don't want to listen to anyone else
that's that's and it happened in the
chatbot industry which I'm more familiar
with than autonomous driving
chat bought this chat about that and
there was an explosion uh it was like a
blob like uh like the internet thing
but now now we can't get away from them
every website we go to it's like leave
me alone like you you're nobody wants to
answer that question like stop nobody
wants to use them I mean because we know
how they work they're
these are stochastic parrots but I mean
it's uh yeah like literally just going
to a fact and hitting Ctrl f is like
more more effective for me I'm trying to
interrupt their chat bot their media
their search engines by key phrases you
put and they bring you a link and they
say read this this is your answer they
are search engines basically and
but again the amount of money because I
lived in that Indus
the amount of money spent on chatbots
will scare the hell out of anybody you
combine that with autonomous driving
both dead almost zero
we're talking billions and billions and
billions and you talk to any one of them
in the highest in the middle of the
fever
they won't listen to you I have people
now calling me back and saying you were
right yeah after 200 billion dollars
so so science is important engineering
is important but science is important
too that's where this the value of this
book is guys hacking alone will not do
the whole thing you're a bright engineer
you can hack your way through what we
know is true that's the space you can
play with
you cannot hack your way in a bigger uh
uh set of possibilities that are
right you didn't verify that you can go
there
you can an engineer can be creative
within a Venn diagram that the
scientists Drew for them
right that's that's good that's the
difference between science and
engineering the scientist draws the Venn
diagram and that's the value of
philosophers at least the analytic
philosophers that no logic and
metaphysics and and quantum mechanics
and philosophers that are on the
technical side
they know how to draw the Van Dyke
you as an engineer if you're wasting
your time here
that's called money down the drain play
inside the Venn diagram
right otherwise
you're just an over enthused engineer
who should go back and study
compatibility
it's kind of like how patent examiners
can easily reject anything that comes in
that claims to violate the second law of
Thermodynamics right but like well
listen Wally like um I think we we
sincerely appreciate your time today and
also Mark thank you for um thank you for
joining us and asking questions we
should do this again
thanks Wally
yeah I really appreciate it so thank you
very much
I see peace